this is a production of Cornell
University alright so today I'm going to
talk about my efforts to characterize
early like tolerance within cultivated
tomato early blight is caused by
Alternaria tomato Phila or Alternaria
Salani it's an echo trophic fungal
pathogen within the city of my seats
this disease is widespread one plant
pathologist described it as present
wherever tomatoes are grown now that may
or may not be true but it certainly is a
problem in him in the humid and
semi-arid environments resistance to
this disease is quantitatively inherited
and the reckon isms underlying that
resistance remain poorly understood but
that doesn't mean that there isn't
substantial resistance within cultivated
tomato in fact while there is no single
gene resistance that provides full
resistance there is quite a bit of
resistance that's already been
integrated in the cultivated germ plasm
and while some mapping studies have
mapped QTL associated with tolerance or
partial resistance to early blight they
generally have had to do or the
generally opinion crosses with unadapted
while species germplasm and they haven't
really advanced into the breeding
programs past that wide cross stage and
so as a result we don't really have any
markers that are predictive for use in
everyday breeding and so that's the goal
for this project that's been my
objective for the last year and a half
or so is to develop some PCR markers
that are predictive of the major QTL
providing resistance to early blight and
then test them in several populations so
what's interesting about the early
blight disease of tomato is that the
resistance to it seems to be somewhat
tissue specific so we have different
responses in the foliage and in the
stems so I'm gonna break this down
during the course of my discussion today
in terms of the foliar and stem
tolerance so starting with this several
years ago Martha began breeding for
northeast adopted fresh market tomato
lines that were resistant to early
blight and also resistant to septoria
leaf
and lately she integrated in particular
resistance in the stems but also found
that that resistance conferred some
foliar tolerance as well under a lower
spray regime but the most market
differences in the stems themselves so
on the top here we have the resistance
genotype this is our resistant control
as you can see there are lesions that
are present but they don't tend to
elongate along the length of the stem
like they do in a susceptible material
and that's important because if you have
a if this lesion elongates and hits a
leaf axle the whole leaf tends to die
and in the same case with the fruits you
actually provide some fruit resistance
by having this form of tolerance because
the pathogen tends to sort of enter the
fruit through the top through the stem
end you actually see here in this upper
right hand corner either the the fruit
is sort of rotting from the stem end out
it's kind of interesting so in order to
map the resistance to this in order to
map that stem resistance in particular
and also to look at the Foley resistance
I worked with three parents and I'm
going to be talking about these
throughout the course of this discussion
our first one is 1510 95 - 146 that's a
Cornell triple resistant line late
blight early blight septoria leaf spot
it's the same one that's pictured here
we also have two Ohio
processing tomato lines Ohio 76063 and
Ohio 75-36 they come from David
Francis's breeding program at Ohio State
Ohio 75-36 for all intents and purposes
is considered our fully susceptible
control and Ohio 76063
actually has some form of foliar
tolerance I should note though that
neither of them are really truly fully
susceptible because they were from a
breeding program that's applied and it's
in a humid environment so like a lot of
reading material that's meant to become
a cultivar it's never fully susceptible
and so in order to do this is mapping
population or in order to do this
mapping I find it out to mapping
populations in the fall of or in the
summer of 2017 an f2 cross between 1510
95 - 146
and seven six six three and a triple
cross that involves all three of these
parents I inoculated him with a backpack
sprayer full of Alternaria North
Carolina number ten is altering its
bottle filler and I did separate
phenotyping for stem and foliar traits
the stem is on the one to five scale and
foliar is on a lunch or on a zero to 100
continuous scale and then I also
measured several importance or what I
thought would be important coat variants
such as fruit size fruit sets fruit
counts and the plant architecture in
general when you look through the
literature you see that as the fruit
size goes up and it's a number of fruit
go up and the internal length goes down
you become more susceptible to early
blight then from this these populations
eye genotypes about half of the f2
population and about a third of the
triple cross population I started with
GPS markers but about a year later it
became apparent that we needed some
where we were missing some genotypes in
some key areas and so we threw some
snips data using the stochastic upset
and so I was able to map resistances to
this stem phase of this disease on 1 4 &
9 the minor effect QTL are somewhere in
the range of 6 to 7 6 to 8 percent real
killer is this guy up here this is
chromosome 9 QTL explains about 1/3 of
the variation for the century that's
major effect locus for the foliar form
of the disease we've got hits on 1 5 8 9
they're all about between 5 and 12
percent they're on the lower end but
that's consistent with the literature
and consistent with what we see in terms
of distributions there are also
significant interactions between the QTL
and between these QTL and other regions
in the genome but for the purposes of
keeping this discussion short slice I'm
only going to be focusing on 3 QTL
that's on 1 5 & 9 these are our biggest
effect additive loci and I want you to
note also that the QTL chromosome
at 9:00 also pop up for this disease so
to confirm the QTL effects we did a few
things to start with I looked at the
genotypes for the f2 individuals that
were used for mapping astray and I
selected based on these QTL regions for
f2 individuals that were homozygous for
all three of the QTL regions in all
possible combinations were possible so
a1 in this case is C 0 7 more six allele
I'm sorry see you 15 295 - 146 allele
and the 3 is the Ohio a 7-6 6-3 Leo and
I'm going to be using this coding
throughout as well and I planted the the
f2 3 families so the progeny will be
selected at two individuals in a
replicated trial this year into Williger
and I sprayed them again with alternate
amount of filler so we did mapping we
did phenotyping for the stem and for
your trades and to start with if we just
look at the distribution of the stem
phenotype about the marker scores so the
genotypes here again are 1 2 & 3 we see
that there is a significant difference
for the phenotype between the markers
and actually when we did that additional
genotyping using the silk a subset the
locations for the QTL shifted a little
bit and so here are the updated QTL
locations I told you that I select for
homozygosity at the QTL but
unfortunately won't change those
positions we introduced some header as I
entered some headers I got to me at the
QTL locations but actually the fit on
chromosome 1 is significantly better but
what may be more convincing is if we
just rank the f2 3 families by their
phenotype so in this case we've got the
stem infection we've got families f2 3
families on rows and as you move down
the table you have increasing disease in
the stems the two key multiple
comparison is used to differentiate the
families statistically and this coding
I've used here is a single plus
indicates
homozygous for the resistant form of the
allele plus minus indicates heterozygous
- indicates homozygous for the
successful and these are the three loci
or QTL on chromosomes one five and nine
and importantly what we see is on
chromosome nine that major effect low
focus is perfectly associated with the
trait so that's definitely encouraging
we do the same thing for fullier ranking
again from most resistant to most
susceptible and you again see that the
distribution of resistant alleles tends
to be associated with plants that are
resistant in fact and again for the
markers chromosomes one five and nine
QTL we do see significant differences in
phenotype as a function of the markers
course looking at this a different way
and using a different population i
generated generated alright i generated
a back cross one individual and so this
is back cross to the recurrent parent
and we use background genome selection
to clean up this material as much as
possible
so actually we select in selecting we
were able to eliminate all but three
chromosomes from play essentially so the
remainder of the genome is fixed
homozygous for this cornell recurrent
parent genome and of those three
chromosomes that are so segregating two
of them are chromosome five in
chromosome nine which are where our
cutie li or two of our cutie li so we
put a segregating population out which
is a self progeny of that bc one
individual and for the stem trait again
we see a nice separation here where as
you move from the Cornell genotype to
the Ohio genotype your you become more
susceptible to the disease and again for
the foliar we looked at the chromosome
five in chromosome nine QTL again
statistically significant separation and
then finally we had before the the last
thing that hasn't been yet confirmed
this chromosome one locus we chose and
have two population
excuse me an f2 individual from this
cross this Ohio 7-6 6-3 by 1510 95 146
and crossed it back to a different Ohio
parents this f2 happened to be fixed for
chromosomes 5 and 9 and so we're
actually amplifying artificially the
effect of the chromosome 1 locus and we
do see effect so I think I hope that
I've conveyed that there's statistically
significant results for these 3 QTL but
what about visual our practicals because
we want to use this in the breeding
program and if we're going to say a line
is resistant if a farmer or a grower
receive this material their claims to be
resistant and it's not we're in we're in
trouble so for that I'm going to take
you on a virtual journey back to free
ville New York in the summer of 2018 on
a sunny day in August and we're gonna
walk through the replicated trial so if
we start with in with a plot enough to
three family that has zero of the QTL
it's fully susceptible as you can see
the plants are not happy there's no
foliage left the stems are all infected
dead total loss we add in a chromosome
one QTL we get some retainment of
foliage but in general all the plants
still look pretty awful same thing with
the chromosome 5 locus chromosome 5 QTL
on its own we add in the chromosome 9
QTL on its own again this looks pretty
awful but if we zoom in on the stems so
as expected it provided a lot of stem
tolerance but not if we start adding QTL
together though then we start getting
measurable results or practically wizard
select practically different results we
see enhancement in the ability to keep
the foliage but in this case we don't
have that chromosome 9 locus and so the
stems are still dirty still infected if
we CRO add in the chromosome 5 and
chromosome 9 together you get about the
same level of foliar tolerance but you
can actually see there are fewer of the
fruit that are rotting prematurely on on
the black plastic here you can see that
in terms of these
these orange and red fruits they tend
actually at this early stage in the
season if you see that it's usually
because the infection is actually
separated the fruit from the plant and
so it's right things with one stone and
when you add all three of the kids yell
together you get a plant that looks
pretty darn good compared to that
initial susceptible plant that was
completely dead and so you and also I
want to point out that I inoculated this
for the backpacks for my material of the
pathogen I sprayed it with overhead
irrigation and I proved up so to
basically enhance the disease and I
didn't provide any chemical control
whatsoever because I wanted this disease
to spread like wildfire so if this plant
is doing as well or if this plot is
doing as well giving those conditions
you can imagine that in a low to
moderate spray regime in a farmer's
field you could actually be doing pretty
well and so with that just talk briefly
about next steps for this project
so um I've I've looked at the effects of
the QTL but I haven't totally controlled
for all the background effects yet and
so for that we really need to generate
some nitrogen declines that are in the
background ideally of both the Ohio and
Cornell material and test the QTL
effects on their own and so we're in the
process of doing that I'm also going to
be doing some selective phenotyping so
I'm going to put a plant out a thousand
or more individuals we're going to use
genotyping to identify some individuals
that have few school accomodates and I'm
going to phenotype using a greenhouse
screen you actually see up here and we
also received some sequence data from
the two parents and so I'm going to be
going through and looking at the
sequences in the QTL locations to try
and identify some candidate genes and
I'll be adding in some digital
phenotyping work to try and enhance this
I've actually begun using this tool
called phenom from my course lab and
hopefully I'll get you analyzing that in
the next
police and then finally we're going to
be creating products with this we want
to be able to use these markers to
generate material that's resistant to
early light late like Victoria and
bacterial spanking bacterial spot the
bacterial side of the project is another
part of reading that I'll be talking
about next year and so with that I'd
like to thank I laughs I'd like to thank
David Francis his breeding program for
providing some of the material and some
support and my graduate committee and
I'd like to thank my funding sources
including Michael was very cool neta for
his class any questions give any
explanation for why that was yeah
so remember I told you I planted out a
triple cross population so that was
supposed to be a BC one back to the Ohio
parent and that's what this is supposed
to be it turns out the cidade was not
what we thought it was it was actually
an f2 selection and so a lot of the Gino
is already fixed so that's why I don't
show an effect plot here because it's
artificially escalated because we a lot
of the genome was fixed we're not
accounting for that and then and then I
guess the second was it was nice to see
all of the stacked genes in fact they
have is it completely additive or do you
argue see but there's stasis I do see
epistasis between the Louis I I am well
I have a few thoughts and I have some
concerns as well so the as I said
earlier the early blade trade seems to
be associated with several prime
architecture traits and so I want to be
sure that what I'm mapping is
just a changing internode length and so
if it's a change in internet length you
can imagine that there would be
interaction potentially like if it was
on chromosome 1 you would expect to see
an interaction between the internet
length and chromosome 9 stem tolerance
QTL and in fact you too and they're
actually pairwise interactions between
all three of the QTL so I'm I have begun
digging into that but I haven't fully
fleshed it out yet so I really I really
need immortal populations or Nils to
test this properly which is what I'm
doing now and Kevin with your plots we
get all three or the QTL stacked up
uh-huh it did look great but they also
looked like the fruit was later in
ripening yeah so that is another
association that you see with early bite
resistance and I'm not sure if this is
due to the early blight resistance or
due to the fact that the fruit part
separating from the plant
so as the infection sort of gets through
the peduncle it separates the fruit and
then the fruit ripens prematurely and so
in those super susceptible material
you'll see a lotta a lot of ripe fruit
right but it's not actually right in
general the seeds wouldn't be viable and
when you touch it the fruits not it's
not actually there it's not physiology B
right it's just it's just French so
again in order to test this properly we
need we need more populations because I
need to be able to plant this out in a
my so my limited understanding of that
is that it it does not frequently if at
all you produce sexually in the wild I
can't answer your question about
lineages necessarily there are two
speech
of this alternate smart fella and
Alternaria Salani ten years ago they
were the same species but they've now
been separated based on I guess someone
host host specificity or Salani is
primarily a potato host and tomato
fellows primarily to meet almost any
other questions so I guess thank you
that was invasion as well I want to do
like you know guys this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu